量子コンピューティングが機械学習を改善できる分野の一つは、
カーネル関数、あるいは
カーネル行列に関連しています。それが何なのかを見てみましょう。
そのために、まず三つのことを確認します。
なぜ内積が機械学習に登場するのか、
なぜ機械学習の問題は高次元を扱うのか、
そしてカーネル関数とは何かです。
まず、n次元の実ベクトル a と
b の内積（ドット積）を
思い出しましょう。これは a の大きさと
b の大きさ、そして二つのベクトルの間の角度 θ の
余弦（コサイン）の積で表されます。これは a の各成分と
b の対応する成分を掛け合わせて
足し合わせることと同じです。ここで注目してほしいのは、二つのベクトルが
ほぼ直交している場合、例えば a の成分が 0 の
ところで b の成分が大きいような場合、
内積は小さくなります。これは
θ が π/2 に近づく状態に対応します。
同様に、a の成分が負で b の成分が
正の場合、
つまりベクトルがほぼ
逆方向を向いていて、
θ が π に近い場合、
内積の結果は
負になります。逆に、a が大きい成分を持ち、b も
同じ符号で大きい成分を持つ場合、
つまりベクトルがほぼ平行で θ がゼロに近い場合、
内積は大きく
正の値になります。したがって、内積がデータ点の
類似度を測る指標として有用なのは、
ごく自然なことです。すべての n 次元データが
n-1 次元の切れ目、つまり直線・
平面・超平面で簡単に分離できるわけではありません。データが
n 次元でうまく分離できない場合、データ点を
より高い次元に埋め込むことができます。例えば m 次元です（m は
n より大きい）。これを特徴写像と呼び、
一般に x を φ(x) に写す写像として表されます。
φ(x) は n 次元の実数空間から
m 次元の実数空間への写像です。
これは
1次元のデータを2次元に持ち上げたり、
あるいは2次元のデータを
3次元に埋め込んだりすると
イメージしやすいですね。
しかし実際には、数千や
数百万次元の空間にデータを埋め込むことがよくあります。
3次元ベクトルの内積と2次元ベクトルの内積の違いは
取るに足らない差ですが、
百万次元ベクトルの内積を
計算しようとすると、
大規模なデータセットには到底適用できません。
そこで、人々は賢いアイデアを思いつきました。
もし特定の射影を使うとしたら？
つまり、高次元への射影に特別な構造を持たせることで、
高次元における内積が
低次元ベクトルの簡単な関数で表せるように
できないでしょうか。つまり、データ x を高次元の φ(x) に写す写像を
見つけることで、
特徴空間における内積が
低次元データの
簡単な関数で与えられるようにするのです。
この関数 k をカーネル関数と呼びます。
理想的には、このカーネル関数が
低次元の
内積そのものの関数であれば、
非常に高次元の特徴空間と
計算コストの低い内積という「いいとこ取り」ができます。
一見すると、
これが本当に可能なのか疑問に思うかもしれません。低次元の
シンプルな例で見てみましょう。
この特定の特徴写像を考えてみます。これは
3次元ベクトルを
9次元空間に写します。実は、
この9次元の特徴写像空間における内積は、
元の3次元空間での内積の
2乗で簡単に表せます。つまり、φ 関数を使って
写像された空間での内積を計算するには、
それぞれのベクトルについて
9つの座標を計算し、
さらにもう一方のベクトルの9つの座標を計算して、
内積を求める必要があります。これは
さらに9回の積と和の計算で、
合計28回の演算になります。
一方、カーネル関数では3回の積と
2回の和、つまりたった4回の演算で済みます。
これは3次元のデータ点を
9次元の特徴空間に写した場合の話です。
より大きな空間では、この差が
非常に大きなメリットになることは明らかです。
カーネル関数は通常、連続関数であり、
データセット内の任意のベクトルに適用できます。
ただし、カーネル関数は
データセットからデータ点のペアを取り、
引数として使います。データセット内の
すべてのペアにカーネル関数を適用すると、
カーネル行列と呼ばれる対称行列が得られます。
どのカーネル関数を使うかは
問題によって異なります。まとめると、
データセット内のベクトルの類似度を表すには、
内積が必要です。非常に高次元の特徴空間での内積は
計算コストが高くなります。
そのため、特定のカーネル関数に対応する
特徴写像を使うことで、
計算をより効率的にします。
ただし、特定のカーネル関数に限定してしまうと、
特徴空間への写像として使えるものが
制限されます。その結果、
データをうまく分離できなくなる可能性があります。
もし別の方法があれば良いのですが。
そこで量子コンピューティングの出番です。
カーネル関数に対応する非常に高次元の特徴写像は、
量子コンピューター上で実行できます。
量子カーネル推定器では、
カーネル行列 k が計算され、
そこから古典的な機械学習アルゴリズムを
使うことができます。具体的には、データ点 x1 を
読み込んで写像し、次に
x2 を読み込んで
写像します。二つの量子状態の内積は
測定確率に関連しているため、
写像された二つのデータ点の内積は、
結果として得られる circuit を十分な回数測定することで
推定できます。このようにして、circuit は
内積について教えてくれます。
circuit がモデル化できるあらゆる高次元空間における内積を、
古典的に内積やカーネル関数を計算することなく求められます。
これらの手法をカスタマイズしたり拡張したりする方法は
数多くあり、
新しい手法が常に提案・
検証されています。この概要が
量子コンピューティングの
機械学習への応用、
特にカーネルを使った手法の理解に
お役に立てれば幸いです。